[Music]
is that because the guys are bigger
because we're spacing the threesome
there's a vertical space but yeah you
have a point there in transition and the
Grizzlies ultimate 11 nothing leave
version 2 summer league enjoy it I don't
think many will in the regular season
mr. Clarke because Doc's been doing it
for a long time right nice tres
migration good look inside Clarke again
he said there's been years where you're
dreading the drive to work and he saw
Mandy yelled at me
that's what I do
but still leave 98 Clarke looks awfully
confident doesn't he did some damage
down low in the first quarter fancyson
connect on a few home runs from time to
time and he's got the max master tax
implication man Andy ellisburg I know
you had to go to in your bag somewhere
though there's a co2 slam well mr. Clark
pick and roll he has been at this room
consistently showing off a vertical
that's special hello front off the cabin
Gilly screams haze goes quick the pump
fake and a better block Clark again
comfortable handling that fall under
duress Harvey back the other way with
the Grizzlies that says a lot of good
things about what they're doing down
there in Tallahassee and the work that
that young man put in Clark
and there's a nice swing to the bucket
in fact if I want to make a team I need
to have a great game against you know a
solidified draft pitch Harvey left me
three he buries it from downtown he
could shoot I pick and roll here maybe
Devon's up top the bucket and the foul
for Brandon Clark yes
vacation here Evans driving throwing it
up and the high flyer going to get it
well-executed do you think Rubio's oh
the Dean trip will try by Harvey good he
got pretty confident without one Clark
don't throw it out he looked at the
defender to say hey what are we doing
his Clark again they said the defender
to accident he wants to under a minute
to play here third quarter down low to
Clark free ball one of my hats this past
nice finish
Clark just before the shot clock expired
radnik Clark's got nine now quick as
possible
Harper nights behind the back pass guess
it's a Willis Willis denied Brandon
Clark coming up with it and he's gonna
run the break I get what you're saying
right away a steal put John Moran
still recovering from injuries so unable
to play the number two pick of the draft
is Harvey the southpaw shooter hits the
jumper leave a guy open in this league
in this summer league and they are
making it is automatic if you want to
know how to make a team don't turn the
ball over play hard defense for Harvey
looks off the pass straight on three
rims and what to do he's just not a big
guy that's long in that letter he knows
he's smart
yes thing I say about was eyeing
Williams to plan Harvey
yeah he looks good shoot yeah 22nd pick
of this year's draft I mean he weighed
260 pounds Catching Fire from the ring
it's good
dusty hatas it's the three she showed
you all the high-flying stuff and there
it goes right from the get-go this kid
Harvey can play
elevator right to the top brandy Klark
at a Gonzaga
puts it down it was on prime Mia 22
it'll take a couple of weeks to get
there by covered wagon to that behind
but we're of a learning year in terms of
being a pro than anything else
Clark got some space as waters backed
off and makes him pay I've always said
he's the best combination of player
winner and enthusiasm of any kid I've
coached her odd I broadcast for India in
the college basketball game by
circumstance they were bootylicious
let's go that way feel free to be
yourself Brandon Clark they've done with
Williams and this is going to be
interesting for his career right there
they drove way but they played behind
Williams into post with length from the
corner three no good for Allen tipped up
missed by Clark Coppola saves it and
with a dozen to shoot
there's the finisher for Brandon Clark
so a triple can get it to four here
Clark says no and emphatically so fact
of referees making a mistake and I don't
mind referees making the style point
beep three trying no the tipping -
therefore Clark impressive week marked
former second-round pick Walker with a
tough shot it was contested well and
back comes Memphis down by six really
anybody outside of Zion Williamson great
athletic bloodlines ten McWilliams
blocked by Brandon Clark and going
straight up Grayson Allen with the ball
had a very quiet first half offensively
Brandon Clark goes glass Evans at the
top of the key he goes up high for
Brandon Clark
he misses but gets his own rebound in
the putback Harvey
dumps it down to Brandon clock with the
two hands tougher
Clark now with 12 between the Memphis
Grizzlies and the New Orleans pelicans
in the MGM Resorts NBA Summer League
Brandon Clark on the move and one
counted and he's been impressive to
start the third quarter
you know dad played in the NBA mom was
the attorney for the WNBA nice
pick-and-roll two-man game in a bucket
by Brandon Clark Candace with a chance
for the last shot and the lead
pick-and-roll and watch the double jump
in the air because that's never been his
game and it's gonna have to be I love
the shooting from deep but it's got to
use that big body
speaking of shooting can deep Brandon
Clark McLaughlin inside search the
contact read that a go strong Brandon
Clark and then he was blocked by Kobo
Glo he stared at Clark and hesitated but
fine by Magoffin Evans from pre point
territory man Memphis is given Minnesota
that work right now from deep the up
turns it over another Timberwolves
turnover there 8 Brandon Clark I was
just about to say he's been loved the
Aussie man he had a cup of coffee last
year with the Nets barfy missing Clark
and he put T up in the weight room
watch him chase the basketball keeps his
eye on it and finishes and you notice
now listen Bates Diop that's what we
talked about mark he had an easy
opportunity to grab that defensive
rebound like I said about the NBA when
you look these max deals and be a stance
were never broke again panis quarter
pocket
it's Harvey the switch barton guarding
him rabbit took post up by Clark's Mary
made him change it but he cleaned up his
mess what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content